moi je me rends compte que les gens qui
sont modérés qui sont prudents qui sont
en quelque sorte centristes pour ce qui
est des questions relatives à la vérité
parlent beaucoup moins que les gens qui
sont extrémistes dans ce domaine c'est
un peu comme au politique les gens qui
sont extrêmes parlent plus que les gens
qui font partie de ce qu'on appelle la
majorité des silencieuse et moi je pense
que notre démocratie pour garder sa
vivacité a besoin que les gens modérés
s'engagent passionnément l'idée même de
démocratie à avoir avec le fait qu'on
puisse argumenter et sont donnés le
temps sans simplement s'imposer
s'opposer pardon avec des arguments
assez primaires qui donnent l'impression
que ce sont des arguments d'autorité qui
se combattent et non pas des analyses